mdr
on sait très bien que c'est parti de la
contamination qui est proposée par les
écoles donc
on accepte de protéger aussi l'entourage
des enfants a pris le métro à paris donc
avant de venir ici à strasbourg et est
ce qui nous a surpris c'est qu'il y
avait encore beaucoup d'enfants qui
portait pas le masque dans le métro
alors que le métro est bondé ça nous a
surpris puisque encore une fois donc
nous habitons madrid le port du masque
est obligatoire et ça pose pas de souci
tout le monde porte le masque à madrid
apparemment télé jean faure qui
transmettraient donc pour pour tout
s'arrête il faut voilà il faut respecter
les lois faut mettre le masque se laver
les mains voilà on doit respecter comme
ça pour que ça finit au plus tôt pour
tout le monde pour les restaurateurs
comme nous pour les boîtes de nuit pour
le théâtre pour le spectacle voilà on a
besoin de vivre et c'est à continuer à
continue bien il y en a beaucoup qui
fermeront leurs portes malheureusement
moi ça me paraît cohérent je pense que
c'est important effectivement que les
enfants
évite la fin qu'on évite la
contamination au maximum
par contre il faut pas que ce soit trop
long fonction pas que ça dure trop
longtemps parce que pense que pour le
développement des enfants c'est
compliqué
[Musique]